my mother has been my role model and
she's told me from the beginning you're
a woman be independent do it on your own
women who want to start their own
business
I think they first need to identify what
they're good at they have to be
passionate about something and that's
the only way business is really gonna
take off but then surround yourself with
people that are different than you are
and bring those people in into your
confidence start out with a very
respectful relationship but but
understand that you need people who have
different qualities I think if you want
to get into the beauty industry you
better know a lot about beauty you
better love it you better go out there
maybe even work in a store to see what
it's like to have that first-hand
experience I know when I'm interviewing
people if I know that they've worked
behind the counter in the industry I
feel like they really do have an
interest in it and then it's all about
networking meeting people talking to
people meeting people in person getting
getting yourself out there and once you
start making those connections things
will start happening I know we've all
heard this before people say to take
risks but what do they really mean by
that and do people actually go out and
take the risk when you get desperate
enough and things aren't looking so good
you have to so don't get to the point
where things aren't looking too good
before we start taking risks
it's most important to be yourself and
not try to be someone that somebody else
wants you to be and once I embraced who
I really am my quirks and my goofiness
and all the little things that make me
different I felt I was able to to become
a better leader and a better manager